So everybody will tell
hire the A players.
Don't bring B players or A minus
players, and that's a no brainer.
Everybody wants the A players.
The whole thing is to get them,
especially when you're small.
So let's say that you're a new company.
You don't have any money at all, or
you are not even worth, you have half
a million or one million in funding.
You supposed to be able to offer
something to your employees,
but you know that you can't because
you have a that it's very limited.
So you can offer all kinds of things.
First of all,
you can offer stock options.
That's, again, that's obvious.
You can offer your first employees
options that hopefully will
get them rich very soon.
Another thing that you can offer them
besides salary, is specific, sorry,
another thing that you can
offer them is benefits.
Some benefits will go a long way, like
health plans and subscriptions to gyms.
It depends on where you live.
If you live in San Francisco,
that's nothing.
But if you live Midwest,
that's something else.
It's more popular there.
The most important thing
that a new company can offer
the employees is sense of purpose and
culture.
Because if you have a good culture,
you have something special,
you have that good vibe
going on in your office.
It's worth more than
money to some people.
People would like to go to work for
you because you give
them an experience back.
You give them the option to work with
amazing people for a great company.
They feel that they really contribute,
and
this is something that goes a long way.
Another thing that you can offer your
new employees is to give them the option
to work with people they see as
important, as smarter than them,
more experienced, people they can
actually learn something from.
People that will help them get
more advanced in their career.
They can learn from, they can build
something special with those people.
And this is something that you
can't buy with money, okay.
It's worth more than an extra 10 or
$20,000 a year.